we have finally figured out what Donald
Trump is doing during some of that
executive time which makes up 60% of
more of his time during some weeks
because we learned that a room sized
golf simulator has been installed at the
White House a big deal is being made in
the media I want to think with you about
how big of a deal should be made about
this in terms of criticizing Donald
Trump and in order to do that we have to
understand what's going on first
remember that Donald Trump said he was
going to be too busy to take vacation
back during the campaign the reality is
that he's taken more golf trips per
month than any previous president at all
during his presidency so far we now find
out that despite the record number of
golf trips per month at a record cost to
taxpayers even when he's at the White
House he might be playing golf on the
golf simulator that he had installed now
some people are already saying who cares
there's a movie theater at the White
House what's the big deal with having a
golf simulator that's no big deal
others will say David Obama also had a
golf simulator at the White House it was
just a cheap one
Trump's is more expensive but he paid
for it himself reportedly fifty thousand
dollars out of his own pocket so who
really cares about that but what those
defenses miss are the real problems here
the real problem
that Donald Trump is almost never
working where is President Obama if
anything worked too much as we found out
from looking at his schedules we now
find out that on top of all of the non
work that Trump is doing he puts in a
new golf simulator the other problem is
that Trump is taking a record number of
golf trips at record taxpayer expense a
hundred and thirty nine trips so far
mostly at his own gun excuse-me golf
clubs which funnels more money back to
himself and that's still not enough golf
he needs a new golf simulator and the
White House is defending this by saying
he hasn't even used this thing during
executive time and he hasn't even used
it at all since it was put it put in
whether we believe that I'm not so sure
the golf simulator though explains so
much of what is taking place at the
White House because executive time
nothing getting done golf outside the
White House this is sort of completing
the picture in addition to the leaked
schedules as to what exactly it is that
Trump is spending time time doing now I
tried to come up with some kind of
silver lining here and one I thought of
is if Trump is playing golf simulator
he's not watching Fox News which gets
him to send really destructive tweets
but even that is probably wrong I would
assume that there's a television with
Fox News on it inside the golf simulator
room so that that probably is not an
upside maybe the only upside pad is what
we've been saying for months which is
anytime Trump isn't working it's good in
the sense that when Trump quote works
he's either passing or promoting bad
policy or ruining relationships with
allies maybe that's the upside to the
golf simulator yeah but then when you
consider Trump not working means that
Mike Pence is taking over people in his
cabinet are taking over maybe that's not
such a good thing maybe we want Trump in
there instead maybe not yeah I mean I
think the real issue is that Trump has
been pretending to be too busy to do
anything other than work forever but in
reality it's recreation it's real golf
it's golf simulator it's watching TV
it's executive time and the picture that
we've been able to put together is one
of a guy who is incipient ly lazy and
barely getting anything done I actually
don't care about the golf simulator in
practice the problem is we know most of
his time is recreational and doing
nothing and the bottom line is that the
golf simulator is only one piece of the
problem and it's actually sort of a
small piece of the problem given how
lazy an ineffective Donald Trump is
today's program was made possible in
part by phantom alert an app that
promotes safe hassle-free driving by
alerting you about things on your trip
like school zones accidents speed traps
speed bumps flooding and a whole bunch
of other stuff on your drive that you
will want to know about before you
actually encounter them
thousands of drivers who use the app
report the warnings in real-time like
accidents and Park Police other drivers
are able to verify and rate the accuracy
of the alerts and then you benefit from
knowing more about the route you're
taking so that your trip is as safe and
efficient as possible
phantom alert says that their database
of traffic alerts is the largest and
most accurate in the world
it is updated every second apps like
this are actually in the middle of a
really interesting political controversy
right now NYPD and other government
officials around the country are trying
to threaten apps like phantom alert
telling them not to allow app users to
notify other users about things like the
locations of checkpoints and speed traps
but apps like phantom alert are actually
fighting back by saying their app is
meant to promote safe driving by
informing drivers of police activity
which lets people be more careful and
make better decisions when they're on
the road never mind
that the police activity like this is
often required to be published on
municipalities own websites so using an
applicant I'm alert is often just a
matter of citizens communicating with
one another about information that's
already publicly available it's a
fascinating debate and I've linked to an
article about it underneath this video I
encourage you to check it out make up
your own mind and also under this video
is a link where you can find out more
about phantom alert as well as download
the app for iOS Android and other GPS
devices like TomTom and Garmin